違いますよ とにかくこの全ての生命に
ですからもう怠け癖というのがありますから
誰にでも この戒やら行やら
そういうものには固執
固く執着するということがあります
そこでこの方が瞑想して
すごい中道を持って瞑想して
ありのまま物事を見てみたところで
体と心のコンディションが素晴らしく最高な時に限って瞑想が進んだことも知っているし
この覚った気持ちも覚ったという出来事も
心と体のコンディションが一番いい時に起きたものだから
それで心が清らかになったんだから
治ったんだから もう戒やら行やら
もうクソ食らいて何の意味もないんだと知ってるんです
何の意味もないんだ 単なるお祭りではないかと
ですから この 2つのヴィチキッチャとシーラッブタ・パラマーサという分の 2つが
まあ別にわざわざ言わなくても 1番目消えるとオマケに消えてしまうちゃうんです
だから頑張って消すのは有身見という煩悩なんですね
消されたら疑いも消えて解言衆と言うんですね
これはもう それも消えてしまう
もう二度と生まれません
生まれるはずがないんだから
決してないです そこで預流果というんですね
1番目のステップに悟ったと
もう進化過程に入りましたと
この進化過程に入るということは
昆虫とかね 卵から虫になったり
いろいろ食べて それからサナギになっちゃうでしょ
それでよく食べてから食べて食べて
もう全部もう栄養貯まったところで
じゃあ糸切りをしようと
自分で何かのこれなりの殻を作って
もう蓋を閉じて中に入ると
それでもわかるでしょ
これ  3ヶ月間でもいいし
1ヶ月間でもいいし 時間さえ待てばいいんです
それであれ破って成虫が出てきますよ
もう蝶々でも何でも どんな美しい姿でも
もう頑張らなくてもいいんです
それはもう前の話で 葉っぱを食べなくちゃいけないし
もう食べて食べて食べて食べて
もう寝る暇もなくて 食べ食べ続けて
まあこれで体が太ったらどうかとか
そんな心配する暇もないし
とにかく食べると それで食べて終わったところでもう終わったら
まあそろそろこれ殻を作りましょうと
もう殻を作らなくちゃいけないでしょ
もう食べることをやめて
これまた忙しくて そこで作って蓋をすると
まあそれでも何にもやることない
そんな感じで まあサナギの状態になったようなことなんですよ
まあそれでも何やらなくたって
もう自然に進化する それ悟れる
ですから その心 預流道心と預流果心と言うんです
で それからはもうさっさと説明します
して終わります 結局ここ終わらないと思う
どっちまで喋るかわからないので
預流道になった人が煩悩は全部消えてないんだから
人間で生まれ変わろうと思ったら生まれ変われるし
例えば死んじゃったところで阿羅漢になってないならば
また生まれ変わります
でも 7回だけ  7回目で確実に悟れるんです
いわゆるもう進化しているんだから
瞑想しようかしなければどうか
それに関係なく 輪廻転生したっても 7回に限りますと
もう大体 7回まで待てる人はいませんからね
それほど もうそれはもう別に怒りもあるでしょ
欲もあるでしょ ですから別に普通にもう食べて美味しいとかいう気持ちがないわけじゃないし
自分に家族がいるならば
家族と仲良くしたいという気持ちもないわけではないし
で 家族の人は子供のためになんかあれやれ
あれやりなさい これやりなさいと言ったらそれもやっちゃうし
子供はどんどん成長してそれ見て楽しいし
そういうのは消えるわけじゃないんです
そこで子供に誰かが悪口で言ってたら
この野郎何言ってるんです
私の子供にとかね 腹が立って喧嘩でも売るかもしれませんし
だからといってもう悟ってないわけじゃないんです
そういうものあっても
もう全ては無常やってことを知ってるんだから
もう自然に心がもう変化して逝っちゃうんですね
といって亡くなっても
もう決して地獄には当たり前で落ちませんし
低次元のところは絶対行きません
一番低次元で言えば人間界なんですね
人間に生まれたって もうものすごい鋭い頭で生まれますよ
まあこれ私のあのガキ頃の観念ですけど
本当 ただのあまり意味がない考え方なんですけど
このあの人 クリシュナムルティという哲学者がいるんですね
日本訳もあります テキストいっぱい
で クリシュナムルティの本をガキの頃読んでみたところで
あまりにも言うことはもうしっかり言ってるし
正確も正確で もうおそらくこの人はもう生まれる前も預流果ぐらいに預流果にはなっていたんではない
預流果にならなきゃこれはわかるはずがないんだと
これぐらいのことをこんな次元で
こんな立場では もうまあふざけて人を馬鹿にして言ってますけど
その中には何か考え方あるんだからね
本読んでみると おそらくこの人はもう生まれる前ね
過去生で預流果にはなっているんだと
僕はすごく思っていた時があったんですね
で そこはそれはあくまで推測ですけどね
僕には超能力ないんだからね
お金で売るならば買ってもつけますけど
で あの 彼がわざわざ別にそういう育て方はなくても
もう彼が生まれる時 前からもなんとなくいろいろな方法で知っていたし
すごい人が生まれるとかね
そこでイギリスに連れて行かれて教育させたりして
特別なこの宗教家として育てられちゃったんですね
でも不思議なことから
生まれつきそういう性格を持っている
すごい頭が鋭くて でも宗教家になるのは大嫌いで
弟子を作るのは大嫌いで
自分の教えさえ哲学としてシステム化するのは嫌で
今聞きなさいと 今聞いて今理解しなさいという感じで
だから自我がないということ見えるんですね
クリシュナムルティ遺産というものを作ろうとかね TM
みたいなすごい組織作ろうとか
こんなもの全くなく 超能力で見せていっぱい信者さん集めようとかね
そういうケチ的なね 品のない概念全くなく
で 一人で生まれて 一人で大きくなって
一人で人々に良く喋って
一人で消えていっちゃった
だからあれほどの性格だからね
もしかすると ですから
まあこれはどうか本当かどうか私もわかりませんだから私は会ったことないんだけどね
まあ我々は人に会う年になってると
その人はいなかった スリランカによく来てみたいんですけど
まあそれはもう昔の話でね
で スリランカってすごいたくさんいたんです
探すと信じる人々が そういうことで
みんなインテリだけで
サイババ信じる人はまた逆で
うん えーと なんとなく言いたがっているのは
この預流果になった人は
例えばもし二度と人間で生まれ変わっても
確実に波乱する人間なんです
他の人にああだこうだと教えてあげたりすることは
これはもう勉強を教えてあげることはできるかもしれませんだけど
人生を教えてあげることは不可能なんです
その人はもう脱せくんである
大勢の人には抜群の効果を与えて亡くなるんであっても
そういうふうなものなんです
ですから なかなかないんですよ
いないんです じゃあそこは置いておいて
七回 最後は生まれ変わる可能性ある
その以前に悟られる 番目はサカダガーミって読むんですね
サカダガーミっていうのはサキという言葉から出てきます
サキっていうのは一回
アーガミっていうのは来る
ですから一来という意味なんですね
一回だけ帰ってくると
いわゆるこの さらに瞑想しちゃうと
その人は第番目のサティを開ける
第番目のサティを開いたところで
その人はもし人間に生まれ変わるんだったら一回だけ
その生まれ変わった時にもう確実に悟ってしまっちゃう
一人もだいたい人間には戻りませんよ
もう悟って みんなもう高次元の方に行ってしまっちゃいますからね
戻ってはこない こんなくだらない人間の世界でね
こんな短い時間でね また喧嘩して苦労して金儲けて食べるためには一生懸命苦労しなくちゃいけない
だから天になんかいた方がもう何の苦労もなくいいでしょうに
来ないことはもう確実に来ないんだけど
それでももう私の言葉で
それでもおバカ者で来たがっているならば
もう一回だけなんですよ
バカ者という言葉を使ってはいけないんだけど
それは大変罪なんですけど
それでも人間に戻りたというならば
一回だけで終わっちゃいます
サカダガーミになった人はどんな煩悩を消すかというと
カーマラーガヴェーパーダという煩悩二つがあります
カーマラーガ カーマラーガというのは欲望
まあ分かりやすく言えば
もう性欲みたいな もうものすごいもう低次元的な
まあよく美味しいものを食べたいとかね
音楽を聴きたいとかね
そういうぐらいの欲なんですね
ヴェーパーダっていうのは強烈な怒りなんですね
強烈な怒り ぶん殴ってやりたくなっちゃうとかね
人に悪口言いたくなっちゃうと
何か怒ってもう何だとか何とか
もうそれそこ ほんの機嫌が悪くなったではなくて
ちょっと怒りなんだ それ二つはどうなるかというと
消えないんですね 弱くなるんです
一来果の場合は ですから
番目の悟っても サイキの普通のサイキの生活をしているんです
でも強烈に 例えば若い女の人だったら誰でもいいんだから追っかけていこうとかね
そこまでは欲がないんです
自分が家族のならば まあそこで落ち着いて
余計なことをしないで落ち着いていると
お金が儲かるんだったら
もうたとえ火の中でも水の中でも飛び込もうということじゃなくて
まあ自分の家族を養えるぐらいで
自分もそれぐらいで悪いことしませんので
余計なお金のためにとかね
いわゆる欲が少ない 怒りの場合も
まあもう怒ったりはするんだけど
まあちょっと怒って それでもう消えてしまう怒りが
人が何かひどいことして
すごくあんたはそこよくないではないかとか怒っちゃうんだけど
もうすぐもう怒りもいいじゃないかってもう消えてしまう
いわゆる弱くなる それでも欲があるんです
そこをどういうことかというと
無常を知っている また瞑想する
瞑想してしてしてやっていると
自分がそれでも生きていきたいという欲がある
あることあるでしょ それでまた
また心の回転ですか 生まれますよ
生まれちゃうと まあそんなに必死に欲を追っかけていかなくちゃっていうのも
まあどうせくだらないんだからね
まあ美味しいことは美味しいんだけど
別に大したことないふうな状態に落ち着くんです
三番目はアナガーミ 阿那含
阿那含 それはこれ一来果
阿那含は不還ですね 還はいりません
不還 いわゆる戻ってこない
その阿那含になった人がこの煩悩二つも消える
この二つはこれで消えてしまいます
欲もない 怒りもない ですから
不還果にならない限りは
嫉妬やら欲やら怒りもない
落ち着いている心は生まれませんよ
そこまではもう追ってくるんです
ですからみんなこの大体気になる煩悩っていうのは結構解きにくい煩悩ですから
やっぱり一来果に頑張らないと頭をしっかりしましょうと
たまたま人生間違ってもいいんじゃないかと
喧嘩して奥さんと一緒に離婚したって
それはそれでいいんじゃないかと
そこそこでということで
それよりはもう頭だけしっかりして
それは順番なんです いきなり来て死んでもわからないのに
頭も悪いのに 私は怒りはなくしてほしいとかね
ぶん殴らなくちゃいけない
物事には順番があるんだから
阿那含になって初めて怒りと欲が消えるんです
それでもまだ煩悩残っているんです
阿那含の人は絶対人間には戻りません
もう来ない 亡くなったら
その人々は梵天に生まれるんです
無料で 瞑想しなくたってもいいんです
いわゆる禅定なんか作らなくたって梵天に行くんです
その梵天は普通の梵天とは違うんです
聖者だけいる次元に行っちゃうんです
だからそれには浄土と言うんです
その浄土の概念なんですね
この浄土という概念として
後の仏教でできたのです
初期仏教の浄土 清らかな場所という意味の浄土っていうのは
もう悟った人々がいるところなんですね
悟った人々だけの特別別荘地みたいな
別荘地と言わないんだけど
他の人には立ち入り禁止
入れません そちらにいる人々はこちらに来ることもない
だからもう来ることない
そこで悟れるでしょ そのそこで悟れる浄土である
そのこと概念二つは膨張して膨張して
この極楽浄土浄という後で考え方が出てきて
南無妙法蓮華経あればそこに行きますよと
でもそれはちょっと甘い話
でもだからで南無妙法蓮華経唱えることは徳ぐらいなんです
それはもう瞑想の一部で
それはいいことで 最後に阿羅漢ですね
今日はもう時間オーバーですけど
何も言ってないんで アラハッタマグってことね
で アラハッタというのは阿羅漢ということで
アラハッタになっちゃったら最終的に全部煩悩をなくしちゃうんです
いわゆるもう無常だからもう諦めたんだけど
いつでもこのだからといって
あの なんてます存在したい
もう生きていきたいという気持ちはそんなに簡単に消えません
まあ死なない限りは生きてきたっても別にいいんじゃないかっていう感じで
まあ生きることにはまだ欲が残ってるんですね
それなぜそんな欲が残ってるかというと
この智慧が現れたんだけど
完璧に徹底的に現れてないんだ
いわゆる 例えば全ては無常
だからといっておにぎり食べたら美味しくないわけないでしょうに
おにぎりも食べられるんだから生きていたってもいいじゃないかというふうに
また別に大したことないんだけど
まあそういうふうな状態になりますから
それは自然な順番なんですね
そのアラハッタマグになったところで
こういう煩悩は消えます
ルーパラード 一つ ルーパラード
ルーパっていうのは色
これ言葉何でしたっけ？ルーパラード
色貪ですか  色貪ですか
色貪 一応色貪 この方です
色貪  うんうん まあラーガは貪りです
執着で渇愛であって ルーパっていうのは色界
あの瞑想して 例えば人間の世界は良くない
畜生の世界は良くない
神々の世界も良くない
ですから梵が一人にならなくちゃいけないとか
人間がもう欲が出ちゃうんですね
阿羅漢になったらこの存在欲は全部消える
たとえ色界であろうとも
そちらに至っても無常は無常だからということで
色界の存在欲は消える
それだけで問題説明終わりなんですけど
まあどうせこういうテキストではもうめちゃくちゃ分析してるんだから全部言わなくちゃいけない
だから言ってるだけ 私の説明だったら存在欲は全部消える
それで説明終わり それで阿羅漢と
で アルーパラガっていうのは無色界に対する欲
次にマーナ マーナっていうのは慢
プライドですね 私がいるという実感から
私はあの人と同じ あの人と同じくないとか
そういうのを測るんですね
測り 測らい すぐ私たちは自分中心に他人を測ってみる
それは阿羅漢になってから消えるんです
ですから いくら修行している人はたまに高慢出しちゃっても
あんまりそこはまあ大きな心で見ておかないと
あのグループには私はもう参加しませんと
あの人はこんなこと言ったんでしょと
まあ僕に言うんだけど
僕にはそういうしょうがないんです
あんたはなんとかしてくれ
私はなんとか それは当たり前じゃないか
いくら瞑想しただけでって言ってもマーナが消えないんだから
それは知ってるし 消えないと
そうじゃなくて みんな我々気をつけて人に迷惑かけるよ
高慢とかね 人に迷惑かけるような自分を低く考える
それを慢だけを抑えればいいんです
だからって慢は心から完璧に消えてほしいとかね
そういう高慢は捨ててほしいんです
慢はあるんだと プライドというものあるんだけど
それはまあほどほどに抑えておきましょうと
人に迷惑をかけないで
人の気持ち悪くなるようなことをしないでおとなしくします
それは修行であって それは戒律であって
消えるのは阿羅漢になってからなんです
次にあるのはディッティ
ディッティかな あのディッティですか
えっと マーナと情動 アヴィッジャ
あ 情動とアヴィッジャ
アビダンマとサンタと
アビダンマの勘定だとこっちの教え方と違うんですね
まあちょっとありますけどね
アビダンマの方は何でしたっけ？ アビダンマの方は
ウッダッチ  失と えっと
イッサと それからマッチャリア
アヴィッジャ  ん？マーナ入ってないの？ マーナありますよ
マーナ えっと イッサ  そう
はいはいはい まあパーリ語だけでいいんです
イッサ マッチャリア アヴィッジャ？ マッチャリア
アヴィッジャ  そうすると六つになっちゃいますけど
これ何ページですか？これはこの分析読んでるみたい
これ分析読んでるんです
200？ 210ページ
一応 お経のお経の作業順で説明します
えーと rūpaṃ rāgaṃ rūpaṃ udaccavedayā
で udacca avijjā
で これはアビダンマの解釈ではなくて
お経で出てくるの順番です
出てくる順番 rūpaṃ
rāgaṃ rūpaṃ ご存知ですね
マナもご存知ですね ウッダッチというのは情動ですから
この心は落ち着いてない状態
混乱状態 ですから これもアラカにならない限りは
もう本物の落ち着きが生まれてこないんですよ
すぐ混乱しちゃうんです
それで瞑想していて よくできたんだけど
もうダメになったとかね
別に落ち込む必要ないんで
そんなものあるんですよ
いくら頑張っても アラカになったらもう落ち着きあるんで
そこに これどういう落ち着きとどういうことかというと
心があれも見たい これも聞きたいという
あっちこっち走り回りたがるでしょ
それはそこから喜びを感じるんだから
アラカになった人にとっては全ては無常だから
そのものから喜びを感じないんです
ですから どこにも別に走らなくてもいい
走りたがらない心が ですから
自然に心が落ち着いている
自然に心が落ち着いて統一状態になっているんです
だから普通に我々はそんな余計な欲を出さなくてもいいんですよ
心混乱して瞑想できない日もあるし
もうすごい嫌な もうやってはいるんだけど
なかなかうまくいかない時もあるし
簡単にいく日もあるしね
そういうのはもう完璧になるまでは色々あります
アヴィッジャっていうのは無明
で 本当はこの煩悩で全て煩悩消える
アラカになる人 なるために修行すると
こんなラーガを捨てようとか全然頑張れないんです
そんなものあるわけないんだから
じゃなくて 無明を捨てようと努力するんです
瞑思するんです この智慧が完璧に現れてほしいんだと
無明で全ては確実に無常であって
無我であって 苦であると
もう極力徹底的にわかると
かすかにわかるんじゃなくて
その通りだと とわかったら
もうこんなものは全部おまけに消えちゃうと
で イッサーとマッチリ
イッサーっていうのは嫉妬
マッチリはケチ そういう煩悩が一来果で不還果で消える
一来果でも一部消える
阿羅漢にはあの不還果になったら全く怒りはない
欲もない ですから嫉妬も何もない
でも比べたりすることはあるかもしれません
で 不還果の人は瞑想して時々チャレンジするのは無明にチャレンジするんです
無明を消してみようと
預流果になる人はまた無明にチャレンジして智慧が現れるようにと
ですからサッカイディッティ
この邪見 有身見という邪見にチャレンジしなくちゃいけない
同じなんです 番目と最後が
修行方法が そこで智慧が現れる
そこで有身見が消えちゃう
消えちゃうとおまけに煩悩2つ消えちゃう
それから感情にチャレンジする
真ん中あたりは 怒りと欲っていうのは感情ですからね
感情消えちゃったところでもう一度智慧にチャレンジする
それでこのアヴィッジャが消える瞬間で
他の煩悩は全部 煩悩は千五百ぐらいありますから
それもその中にまとめているんです
それももうおまけに消えてしまう
簡単に 全ての煩悩はアヴィッジャに基付いています
アヴィッジャから発生するんです
煩悩は一つしかないというならば
アヴィッジャしか無明しかないんです
無明だから怒る 無明だから嫉妬する
無明だから結集する 無明だから怒る
無明だから欲が出てくる
そんな順番でね 一言だけ言い忘れちゃって
その悟ると何を対象とするんですかと
心にはいつでも対象があるんです
壁があって見ている 音があって聞いている
この対象を取る限りは
際にならなければ 音はここにあるんだからね
で 概念があって妄想する
そういうわけで 心があるということは対象を取っていることだから
ですから 心があるということは
世間の中にいるということだ
そうすると心があって出世間離覚は終わりません
矛盾なんです 心が活動するということは
世間の中で対象を取っていること
世間次元の中 そこでたった一箇所だけ
ある瞬間で心は対象を取らないということをするんです
すべては無常だと分かったら
もう何対象を取ったって
もう嫌でもう落ち込んで
もうもうどうしようもない状態で
そこで心がもうそれでもヴィパッサナーでやってるんですよ
自分でやらなくなっても
もうもうもういつでも確認状態でいるんですね
そこで心はある瞬間だけ
あまりも嫌だから対象にいかない
取らない この取らない瞬間なんです
悟りというのは 何も対象取らない瞬間
次の心であの瞬間は素晴らしかったと
本当は自分がいるという概念もその瞬間でないんです
全て消える 全て消える
自分がいるという概念さえない
全て消えた瞬間 次の瞬間にまた自分がいるんですね
いる瞬間であ あの瞬間が素晴らしかったと
と そこで預流果というんです
預流道ではなくて その対象を取らない瞬間なんです
それはもう回しか生まれませんよ
一人の生命には それ阿羅漢になってから
この禅定もできてから
いく何回でも作ることができるんです
それは後で 心止まること
我々の否定的な言葉で言えば心止まること
対象を取らないようにすること
それは阿羅漢になって
それからその上プラスアルファで禅定の経験もある
夜四禅定まで四禅定まで心止めて
それからこの瞑想ヴィパッサナーに入って
阿羅漢果という心が作る
作っちゃったら心はストップ
体もストップ 全てのエネルギーはストップしちゃうんです
まあそれで楽ということだけのことですね
そこでもやっと終わりました 5
時まですいません  [拍手]